foreign
I've been thinking about freezing my
eggs
but before we go deep into that decision
come with me 20 years ago
a small beautiful mostly Catholic and
very conservative City
around two hours north of Mexico City
I made your souls and I've decided that
I am not having kids
all I've seen all my life is that having
kids will slow down my career
but I want to become a doctor when I
grow up
all my friends moms do is stay home and
take care of us kids
I thought that this was the door
but one day my mom told me how she
always dreamed of becoming a
psychologist and helping others
but she had to give up this dream the
moment that my brother and I were born
I was devastated I couldn't stop
thinking about all the people that she
would have been able to help
but I was far from being alone
in our generation Millennials and gen
seers more than 30 percent grew up with
a stay-home mom
the previous generation was different as
more than 60 percent grew up with a stay
home
our grandmas were told that they had to
stay home and take care of kids no
questions asked
just as their mother said and their
mothers before them
Choice was not a worth in their
vocabulary
our moms were different
for the first time in history they were
given a choice
study and have a professional career or
have a family
they could choose one or the other but
not both
and today
thanks to all the amazing technological
advancements and specifically through
the science of egg freezing we Face a
very different question
can we focus now when we are young full
of ambition and energy on our careers
and have kids later in life
can we truly have it all
to the men in the audience
thank you for being here you might be
wondering does this even apply to me
well if you've ever thought about having
kids now or in the future or if you're a
father today this applies to you
so what is egg freezing
most people have at least a basic
understanding of what egg freezing is
but there are so many questions on our
minds
what's a procedure like do I need to
undergo anesthesia at what age should I
do it is it risky is it painful does it
even apply to me so many questions
but don't worry I've got you
everything is a process in which a
woman's ex are extracted Frozen and
stored for later use usually in the next
5 to 10 years
this is typically a minimally invasive
outpatient procedure and it requires the
use of local or general anesthesia
depending on the patient
egg freezing has many different uses
from health concerns to Identity choices
to decisions in the timing of your
career this last one is usually referred
to as social everything
now I want you to meet my friend Lisa
Lisa is 35 years old
and she always has dream of having four
kids
even though she wants to say to get
pregnant now she worries whether she
will be able to have the family of her
dreams or not
women are born with a finite number of
eggs
and this number decreases as women age
as published in the UCLA Journal of
women
a women's fertility drops from 86
percent when we are 20 years old to 52
percent when we are 35 just as a case of
Lisa to only five percent when we are 45
years old
now this doesn't mean that women can get
pregnant and carry a child as they grow
older
but given that our fertility is so low
the chances of naturally getting
pregnant decrease significantly
however recent Studies have shown that
during the procedure of egg freezing if
you're able to retrieve 20 or more eggs
the chances of giving of having a life
birth rate increases up to 70 percent
and the younger that you freeze your
eggs the more likely it is you will be
able to retrieve this number
now I want you to meet my friends Maria
just graduated from college and she
struggled to enter a very competitive
industry and she wonders how far should
I go into my career before shifting my
attention to having a family
women's fertility window coincides with
the most important years of career
advancement and productivity
but as women decide to have their first
child later in life
social egg freezing provides us with a
viable solution to be able to focus on
our career now when we are young and
ambitious
and be able to have a family later
without having to sacrifice one or the
other
social egg freezing does not guarantee
getting pregnant in the future so don't
believe those that tell you that egg
freezing is an insurance policy and
there are many considerations that you
need to talk with your doctorate
but to me
everything is empowering
there are many benefits to women taking
control of their fertility
and freezing their EX
we can draw parallel back to the 1960s
when single women gained access to birth
control pills
during the 20 years after this the
number of females lawyers doctors and
judges multiplied between four times and
13 times in the U.S alone
can you imagine having the number of
women becoming scientists startup
founders
Partners at BCS and hedge funds
multiplying like this again
everything can become our generation's
way of going around the biological glass
ceiling
and allowing us to focus on our career
without having to sacrifice our fertile
years
and be able to have the family that
would always wanted to
now lastly I want you to meet Priscilla
Priscilla has thought about freezing her
eggs for the past year
but she hasn't even started the process
because of what egg freezing says about
her
she grew up having a very clear idea of
when and how she wanted to start a
family
and everything means that she was unable
to achieve this
so if you're thinking right now why me
why now
I know it can be scary
but just as you wouldn't join a company
without doing any research about it or
you wouldn't make any financial decision
without knowing how much money you have
in the bank
we need to have all the information
and whether everything ends up being for
you or not or the special women in your
life
information is power
so if you're anything like Lisa Maria or
Priscilla
in your 20s to your early 30s go and
gather all the possible information
learn about your ovarian reserve your
fertility status talk to your doctor
one simple and inexpensive way of doing
this is through a fertility blood test
you'll be surprised at how valuable this
information can be
and if you're anything like my mom over
your 50s not thinking about anything
related to Motherhood or if you're a
current or prospective father
help us go out there and learn about all
the technological advancements and
Alternatives that exist out there
you can change our lives
my life certainly changed the moment
that I learned about all of this
and as you can imagine my mom now is
over the moon at the possibility that
she might become a grandmother someday
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]